du bist tot
nein du musst nicht tot ich bin jeden
moment ich bin total warum denn ist das
scheiße ich versuche jetzt und blauen
baum hier an denen haben wir gesagt wir
nicht abkühlen
da hinten aber auch noch mal so ein
komischer blauer baum ich möchte auf
jeden fall so klaus holtz haben
wenn wir gleich das fertig gebraten
haben können wir immer so ein bisschen
die richtung weiterlaufen und dann
finden wir bestimmen was übrigens man
muss nicht immer mit anderen leuten
aufnehmen
ich habe das jetzt nur mit den er
gemacht nicht weil ich gegen die nets
finden oder so sondern einfach weil ich
eine person braucht die mir das alles
erzählt ja ich bin nur nicht krieg auch
um geld dafür den als ihr nur der der
der quoten limbo der hier einfach mit am
start dreimal kopf ist doch besser
dachte ich jetzt oder naja aber darauf
kann man sich ja keine werkzeuge machen
er glaube ich weiß es nicht sondern
warum ist es dann besser als eisen was
kannst du in rüstung ist besser und du
kannst dir aus gesunder cable machen
körper cable ist damit das a und o wenn
du ihn was maschine das machen möchtest
ich dachte das ist es ja dass so auch
über kopf- bauch- und warum man nimmt
man das eine war nimmt man das andere
du bist übrigens mein quoten ich weiß
ganz bisschen was von der wenig anlass
zum besten was der unterschied zwischen
den beiden cables ist es gibt koffer
cable und dass wir uns und rapper kay
one ein rabatt apple gibt sich die
branche in europa und kopf um
kupferkabel hinzukriegen
jetzt verstehe ich als das zu
kompliziert alles also wenn ihr
irgendwann besser besseres wissen wir
also alles dann schreibt einfach in die
kommentare ich meine da ist endlich
platzt und ja
und am besten dann auch immer
ausführlich erklären wie das geht nicht
einfach jahr macht dies und dies
entweder und so macht doch einfach mal
da sind wir gut und wir stehen aber es
gibt ja auch eine funktion ich weiß
natürlich schon kennst du kannst
irgendwie in einem inventar gehen dann
kannst du oben den rest api mode an
machen
dies machte wie geht das ich hab's nicht
wieder vergessen
da egal regal gehen dass wir den kopf
geschlagen habe du musst in asse zu
drücken drücken dann drücken und dann
traue ich mich ich bin schön
ressentiment sich gerade da muss unten
links auf options gehen
ich bin schon raciti motto ich auch ja
was mache ich dann aber du kannst dann
einfach dann unten siehst du den
schwarzen balken einfach wirst du
schwarz wie dein herz ja so da kommt dem
opfer ein
ach so da geht man was ein koffer cable
kopper leerzeichen cable er sehe ich
dann siehst du da kupferkabel 30 1843
klick darauf und dann siehst du oben
herab und darunter sie zu kopper in gott
und das alles zu unseren körper cable zu
machen und das sind diese kabel das ist
nicht gut das match börgermann koffer
oder man kann körper in gott ja da gibt
verschiedene sachen die man machen kann
aber auf jeden fall kopper
das sind zwei verschiedene sachen du
musst dann jedenfalls dieses kopper
cable ist quasi die redstone nur es ist
halt so ein fettes kabel also sieht halt
wirklich auf seinen blog quasi mehr oder
weniger wie sonst kann das vergleichen
weil sie nicht es ist halt wie so ein
blog und er verbindet sich somit
maschinen und dann wenn du zum beispiel
generator hat sagen wir mal
sagen wir das hier ist der generator
dass ihr okay und sagen wir moment also
das jetzt sagen wir das hier ist der
generator und das ist ein moment sein
wird das ich dir verbindung
allerdings brauchte dann hat mehrere
verbindungen also hier das wort zu
wertvoll als dass dann dann verbindest
du dass du miteinander das ist dann so
ein kabel da kannst dann auch darauf um
hüpfen und alles und dieser generator in
denen musst du dann zum beispiel kohle
rein tun weil dann läuft er die ganze
zeit und dieser generated ergibt dann
die power über das kupferkabel ab an den
märkten und in den mails retter kannst
du dann zum beispiel rabatt reintun und
der macht dieses rabatt dann zu
irgendwas anderem zum beispiel wer weiß
nicht wirklich verstanden
es geht aber das ist die hauptsache
und ja das ist wie bei der nacht
übrigens aber jetzt haben wir beide
waffen und das habe ich so gelernt in 70
folgen feed the beast ja so ich habe
jetzt auf jeden fall schon mal reisen
sachen das heißt manstein sachen wäre
ich wahrscheinlich soll wieder
wegschmeißen oder ich weiß nicht ich
brauche dich mal holz ich weiß nicht ich
wieder zurücklaufen ich wollte ein
bisschen farbe nämlich wird sagen noch
ein bisschen mal in eine höhle weil wir
voll wenig erhöhen sachen gemacht aber
ich habe schon eine höhle gefunden die
relativ große aussage ich warte man da
rein oder nicht
davon war ein wollen wir uns noch scharf
erholen dass wir uns eventuell noch
betten machen können an die können uns
am nächsten tag einfach holen die sachen
und nehmen einfach mitnahm alles abbauen
hier bloß wenn mein ganzes fleisch für
sich genommen was du einfach stibitzt
sorry keine dick für ein kind kommt 2
abt 230 stück reihe kriegs 2 ja
das ist viel das sind ja das sind wie
das gut mithalten kannst dann sogar noch
den könig ab da ich würde also
kellereien wie du ja henning ich habe
viel mehr ist weg als du wenn du bist
bloß ne kuh und die macht so wie du
glaub ich die höhle irgendwo ja genau
hier haben keine rein gepflanzt inhalte
und dieses grüne daumen das ist glaube
ich uranium das ist auch mein ja das hab
ich auch schon gefunden hab schon mal
auch an ihm gefunden und dann wo ich
gekillt ehrlich mensch guck mal hier zur
a niemals gesehen dass uranium gefunden
und jetzt wird's gekillt
ich hab nicht mal eisen sachen ich habe
eisen sachen aber erst noch hast noch
drei eisen für mich übrig nämlich auch
eisen man kann menschen kommt dann
siehst du machen wir beide ein
friedenspakt schließen
da freut es reden wolf rollt also dass
wir dass wir uns nicht gegenseitig
einfach so in der pampa töten sowie
andere spieler in anderen serien jetzt
leider abgebrochen worden aus komischen
vorkommnisse was ich erinnere mich dann
eine sendung wo sich zwei streitfälle
irgendwann ja wenn ich das war
das war eine sehr schöne sehr ich fand
die sehr geil da muss man sich auf jeden
fall anschauen oder ja wie auch sagen
und am besten zu 1000 mal jede folge
sodass auch diese casting menschen
verein gesammelt
ich dachte ich hab sie eingesammelt aber
ich hab's nicht mehr inventar ich hab
sie ja aber ich habe sie abgebaut gehabt
das ist aber natürlich so dann kann ich
mir jetzt auch noch mal gleich endlich
etwas abbauen so sehr schön danke danke
auch wenn wir so gut bei mir auch schon
die ganze zeit face kann man staatlichen
wie lange noch durchhält
sie kann sein dass sie gleich einfach
wieder was jetzt hier da springt einfach
mal vorbei sondern geht der weg nicht
gedacht da unten hier sieht irgendwie
besser aus unter der höhle fast schon
wieder vorbei jedoch nicht ist diamanten
voll voll selten geworden sind in apps
ich hab grad diamanten gefunden sind
keine diamanten
ich werde mein haus hauptsächlich aus
marmor
die marketingassistentin ohr den ort
ziehen und daraus gemacht und was machst
du dir darauf weiß ich nicht ich bin
jetzt auch kein experte aber ich habe
uns auf jeden fall durch den krieg war
schon ein großes loch gemacht das können
nur experten und durch das loch sehe ich
gerade dass es da und noch viel weiter
geht
der jubilar war schon jetzt hier ich
hätte aber gerne kohle damit ich mir am
sa 4 gefunden saphir und rubin das ist
genauso die eisen nur hält länger ja ich
erinnere mich auch an ein rubin front
aber danach bin ich auch wieder
gestorben
echte elendig verreckt ja übrigens ein
mann ja auch sehr viele herren hatten
sich jetzt mit dem er gestritten oder
warum nimmt
jeder zweite mann mir auch viele beweise
dass du dich dass du dich zerstritten
kontron mit ihm auch beweise ich bin
auch darauf gar nicht eingegangen weil
ich hasse solche sachen diese die pferde
darum auf das war mate über noch ein
bisschen strom einem skelett das hat mit
meiner oma ab 16 machen
der strom wie stroh ich habe 2 31 06
stell dir mal vor schon von nein bei mir
verweisen weizen als ist jetzt geht auch
so strohballen ehrlich für die pferde
für die pferde er genau ich weiß dass
ich den traum so schön haben so mäßig
sagte etwa das ja fackeln mehr als genug
ja ich habe auch kassel kohle und sache
ist jetzt allerdings nur dass wir in der
1.6 oder sieben spielen sieben glaube
ich und daher haben wir noch nicht die
features der 1.5 und auch nicht 1.6
logischerweise das heißt wenn jetzt
meinte haye macht euch doch mal werdet
dann nicht klappt nicht so toll habe ich
auch keine verkündet
aber dafür hat viele bisher 1000 andere
tauschen eine andere sachen genau das
heißt wenn wir lassen hier reiten wir
einfach auf die na was ist das grüne was
leuchtet erst erörtert scherbe und was
bringt die person eine seltene erde kann
ich mir ein pop damit bauen
do kann ja du kannst du deinen ipod oder
halt samsung galaxy dastehst mir mehr
drauf okay da auch drauf bauen nähe
nicht nehmen nexus gerät nexus mit mit
echtem android und nicht irgendeine
schlechten hersteller aufsatz der
schlecht ist das wie auf dem mond hier
wo ich gerade bin
bei mir sieht komisch auch einfach mit
mir ist einfach überall mama und so
komische gängen und überall lang also
nicht eine normale wir haben da gar
nicht drauf klar ist auch voll wenig
eisen und so etwas ändern
ich brauch holt weil dieser in 11
städten
denn ja du bist hart ich weiß nicht oder
soll ich hart pro werkstück nach links
geht dann gucke ich ihn an
aber dann hat er mich angeguckt quasi
ich müsste doch dann aus ich hab ihn
angeguckt ok bloß auf sterblich ich geh
einfach zu dir was auch ja hallo euro
scheiße es gibt es solche zombies mit
roten augen die kill nicht immer
ja ich habe gesehen was auch immer 30
meter von mir weg auf einmal 40 und du
bist immer runter gefallen hmmm das
schöne bild mich auf meiner karte sich
auch die ganzen zombies und monster sich
gerade wenn es angeblich direkt über mir
ich sehe im moment direkt neben mir ich
dachte erst da greift mich an ich war
schon voll panisch ich eine karotte
gefunden das zu ändern wäre nämlich mag
da unten denn mit dem blog innerhalb der
dreht sich die ganze zeit im kreis ja
ich kann dir nicht an also das habe aber
nicht gesehen der rasse gleich richtig
aus ich dir helfen glaubt jetzt richtig
wütend 0 durch stehe um warum also der
macht irgendwie gar nix ich würde jetzt
irgendwie affig ich hab die ganzen holz
hier bei mir
ich fühle mich voll schlecht oder ohne
rüstung so als ob ich als ob er jeden
moment sterben könnte so fühle ich mich
auf reisen auch nur doch ich hab ich
habe noch 16 eisen sodann stellt mir
jetzt erst mal in fahrt auf dann nämlich
jetzt tickt einfach verfolgt und ich hab
nicht mal kohle
es ist so traurig ja ich könnte mir aber
nicht mal auch so ich liebe gelitten hat
ist blaue hier frage ich mich
8 a 44 ist gut hast du gesagt gaddafi
rubin ist gut aus kannst du dir waffen
machen die sehr gut sind und die sind
dann so grün und rot die sind voll geil
aus ok kann man sich ausrüstung machen
ja ich glaube auch ich werde mich ihnen
heute mir kein brustpanzer bisher machen
obwohl doch kann es machen weil aber da
kommt nach erhalt das jetpack drauf auf
diesem platz und übrigens wenn ihr
rezepte willst et cetera element direkt
vor mir wirklich haerlin oder nicht und
kongress wieder weggegangen
einfach mal wo bist du
die 78 meter schaffe ich yes yes yes
ja wirklich wieso fick dich schreiben
die begeisterung hier balkon crafter
mache ich vielleicht auch diamanten jung
ich habe der frau gesucht und mich
gehört bisher war das eine folge lang
gesucht sie minuten direkt von der seite
kommt das wären diamant und dann ist
sicher dieses team
ich hasse das denkmal ich habe noch drei
eisen geschenkt das ungefähr so viel
wert wie 10 jemanden wie ich sagen
bei dem geld nach den rückschlägen in
den letzten folgen jetzt habe ich neun
stück neun stück uns nicht tot
ich bin jedem moment ich bin total warum
denn ist das scheiße kk ich warte ich
aber in sachen die meisten sind nicht in
der lage aber ist der weg ist nicht
allzu schwer ist des point umhergelaufen
ich pass auf was machst du denn auch ich
hab schon gemacht oder man bleibt oben
dann bin ich dagegen gesprungen oder
gefallen
du hast den gleichen fehler gestalten
oder bitterfeld spaß einfach nur da alle
schaffen und wir sind schon über sage
ich angegriffen
springt sich um eine mobile aufnahme wo
dort nicht angehalten
egal wie daraufhin über mir sofort 60
metern noch erwischt gegen das denn
ja ich bin gespannt
wer baut denn hier einfach so steine in
wegen irgendwas weil ich gerade
einstellen aber ich bin ich weiterhin
was auch so falls meinte löschen
340 meter